they want to control his thinking but
dave chappelle isn't blinking the
comedian sticks to his guns defending
free speech comedy and fun in a new
video he's addressing the protests over
his new stand-up special and his
comments about the transgender community
that's after netflix employees staged a
walkout last week which was intended by
tens of people
i've seen more people in hemmer's hot
tub
plus a few animals i wonder it's been
said in the press that he was invited to
speak to the transgender employees of
netflix and he refused
as we said in the press
that i was invited to speak to the
transgender employees of netflix and i
refuse
that it's not true
if they had invited me i would have
accepted it although i am confused about
what we are speaking about
i said what i said and boy i heard what
you said
my god
how could i not
you said you want a safe working
environment at netflix well it seems
like i'm the only one that can't go to
the office anymore
he's not wrong if he walks into that
place today they treat him like an
active shooter
chappelle also revealed that his
documentary about his 2020 summer comedy
tour has been expelled from film
festivals this film that i made was
invited to every film festival in the
united states and some of those
invitations i accepted
and when this controversy
came out
about the close-up
they began disinviting me from these
film festivals
and now
today
not a film company not a movie studio
not a film festival nobody will touch
this film thank god for teds randalls of
netflix he's the only one that didn't
cancel me yet
then he went on to speak directly to the
trans community i wonder if he said if
you want to meet with them he's more
than willing to but has some conditions
and if you want to meet with me i'd be
more than willing to
but i have some conditions
first of all
you cannot come
if you have not watched my special from
beginning to end you must come to a
place of my choosing
and a time
of my choosing
and thirdly
you must admit that hannah gatsby is not
funny
[Laughter]
that's funny because it's true
gatsby was among those who denounced
chappelle's special and blasted netflix
ceo over his response to all of it i'm
told she's also got a few netflix
specials though they're the only
specials with a trigger warning that
reads will not induce laughter
joe was that fair ah she's not unfunny
or is she oh well so far we've heard
from people who can't take a joke now
we've heard from someone who can't tell
one
geez
she's pretty bad
uh
yeah you know when her special came out
they they actually tried to say oh no no
this is a different kind of comedy and i
had all these messages people were
sending me saying comedy doesn't have to
get laughs comedy doesn't have to be
entertaining
yeah and finally i had to block joe
mackey
[Laughter]
by the way well never mind i was going
to make a very disgusting joke but i'm
going to say one more thing about this
netflix protest that i knew it was going
to be there were so few people there
they weren't even worried about covet
rules yeah it was like a dozen people
and you can tell because the cameras
yeah are from this club if any closer
those cameras would be performing a
colonoscopy so don't don't fall for what
they're saying this is they don't
represent a large group of any people
let alone this community they're talking
yeah that is so true whenever you see
any kind of news story where the camera
is close up for a group that tells you
there's no group
tyrus uh i is this all part of a
brilliant rollout of his special he
actually turned his adversaries into
publicists i mean so many people now
know more about this than anybody you
know i i would think maybe but uh
chappelle is one of those ones brothers
not driven by money and fame he walked
away from 50 million so i i can't see
him putting himself through this uh his
family through this uh just to get to
watch because they're going to show up
to watch
what i think needs to happen though is
some of us have to come forward i think
it's time i came forward i wrote the
jokes i'm sorry
it was me i can't let chappelle take all
the heat anymore
i did it so come get me you know they
go after him so hard
and they pushed so hard that he was just
you know he was transphobic and he was
attacking people and they tried to
compare it to other things
and i for one was like well when do i
get my turn to complain about dave
chappelle all the light-skinned brother
jokes he's made over the years always
talking about how handsome we are how we
get the jobs and the girls like it's
it's unbelievably upsetting so maybe we
should go you know how many times he
said the n-word on tv why are we not
getting him oh because he's black he
gets a pass no sir so let's just give me
my platform so we can go after him and
another thing which is
really great and i wish you know when
you talk about a group being or a group
coming after you as the people who are
saying that you know it's causing hate
i one of the things that i always
enjoyed about when they had clan
meetings at the end of every clan
meeting after they talked about getting
rid of all the [ __ ] from the
neighborhood uh usually it was mordecai
would come up at the end to discuss the
scholarship funds that they set up for
all the minority children so they can
get a good education afterwards because
that's literally what dave chappelle did
to the gentleman or to the woman sorry
that passed away he got a scholarship
for her childre for her children right
but that's normally what you do when you
want to hate a group is you pay for
their kids to go to college yeah that's
what he did if you watch the special
that's what he ends up doing matt what
do you what do you make of this i don't
know i just feel like the only good
thing about chinese corona and a
pandemic is that a lot of us watched a
lot of television and we
all these controversies came out about
what's on and what's not on and all you
know you know what the best tv show of
all was or whatever for those of you who
have kids we got to listen to what's
going on in their school in the
classrooms right oh my god yeah that's
why this firestorm's going on in
virginia and i say to dave chappelle and
to you
it's nice to have comedy that's funny
yeah i think if the country could laugh
a little bit uh maybe we could all get a
little better mood yeah it's good it's
good that you have somebody uncancelable
cat like him he's got the money he's got
like he what he's doing is what jerry
seinfeld should have done other people
who are worth half a billion dollars but
he's actually doing it to protect people
who could be canceled or doesn't have
the money or the will for me yeah i
can't imagine having money and never say
like why
but you just said it twice and you don't
have i don't have that much money
you must have fu money if you're going
to drop the effort but they do and they
don't anyway and it's also people i saw
some columns about this and you know
yeah he's saying he only wants to meet
with you know certain trans people i'm
like oh you mean he's treating trans
people like individuals
isn't that what work he said the same
thing is special like i would have trans
friends if you know they're funny people
that we do that all the time with each
other you're supposed to treat other
people as individuals like regardless of
gender race isn't that you know sexual
isn't that we are what we are supposed
to be doing this is going to be the
topic of our next block about the idea
that it's not about the identity block
it's about who are the jerks versus the
non-jerks that's how we should be
segregating we should be segregating the
jerks from the jurors
right i like it all right
up next
he couldn't say anything nice about
condoleezza rice